que ce dermatologue était aussi formé en ophtalmologie.
Notre jour de chance.
J'en étais malade.
« Ome ? »
« Ome » c'est comme mélanome, lymphome --
un cancer.
« Est-ce que vous cherchez une éruption cutanée dans ses yeux ? »
Je crie et ne fais pas de bruit.
Alors voilà.
Elizabeth est atteinte de pseudoxanthome élastique.
Abrévié PXE.
Les questions se sont mêlées à la peur
et ont surgit telle de la bile dans ma gorge.
Pourquoi regardez-vous dans ses yeux ?
Que savez-vous à ce sujet ? Comment pouvez-vous être sûr ?
Quel est le prognostic ?
Ma formation de conseillère pastorale ne m'a pas préparée à cela.
Le docteur Bercovitch nous a dit tout ce qu'il savait au sujet du PXE.
C'est une maladie génétique rare,
elle est systémique,
c'est une maladie de vieillissement prématuré qui évolue lentement.
Elle peut entraîner une peau flottante et ridée dans les zones des fléchisseurs.
Elle entraîne la cécité,
la dégénérescence maculaire
et une foule de problèmes cardiovasculaires.
On en sait peu sur cette maladie
et certaines personnes meurent vers la trentaine,
d'après certains rapports de l'époque.
Il a ensuite jeté un œil à notre fils et dit :
« Il est aussi atteint ».
Nous voulions fuir, retourner au pays de la normalité.
Deux jours après Noël,
des chercheurs sont venus de l'université de Boston
et nous ont prélevé du sang, à nous et à nos enfants,
pour un projet de recherche se concentrant sur la découverte du gène.
Quelques jours plus tard,
des chercheurs du centre médical de New York
voulaient également du sang.
« Ce sont des enfants.
Ils ont cinq et sept ans.
Ne leur infligez pas à nouveau une aiguille.
Partagez avec les autres chercheurs. »
Ils ont ri, incrédules.
« Partager ?? »
Nous avons alors appris
qu'il y a peu de partage dans la recherche biomédicale.
Ce moment-là, plus que tout autre,
a allumé le feu en mon mari Pat et moi.
Dans une bibliothèque de fac de médecine,
nous avons copié tous les articles que nous avons trouvés sur le PXE.
Nous ne comprenions rien.
Nous avons acheté des dictionnaires et manuels médicaux
et avons lu tout ce qui nous tombait sous la main.
Même si nous ne comprenions toujours pas,
nous voyions des tendances
et, en un mois, il est vite devenu évident
qu'il n'y avait pas d'effort systématique pour comprendre le PXE.
En plus de cela,
l'absence de partage rencontrée était généralisée.
Les chercheurs étaient en compétition
car l'écosystème était conçu pour récompenser la compétition
plutôt que de soulager la souffrance.
Nous avons réalisé qu'il nous faudrait travailler sur cette maladie nous-mêmes
pour trouver des solutions pour nous et les autres comme nous.
Nous faisions face à deux obstacles majeurs.
Le premier :
Pat et moi n'avions aucune formation scientifique.
A cette époque-là, il était gérant d'une entreprise du bâtiment
et j'étais une ancienne aumônière dans une université, mère au foyer --
ce n'étaient guère des formations
pour prendre d'assault le monde de la recherche.
Le second obstacle :
les chercheurs ne partagent pas.
On nous a dit que les chats ne vivaient pas en troupeau.
C'est possible, si l'on déplace leur nourriture.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
L'ADN et les données cliniques sont la nourriture.
Nous collecterions du sang et des antécédents médiaux
et exigerions que tous les scientifiques utilisant ces ressources
partagent les résultats entre eux et aux gens ayant fait des dons.
Avant qu'internet soit aussi répandu,
Pat et moi avons établi PXE International,
une organisation à but non lucratif consacrée à l'initiation de la recherche
et à sa réalisation pour le PXE
et soutenant les individus atteints de la maladie.
Via les médias traditionnels,
nous avons réuni 100-150 personnes à travers le monde
à qui nous avons demandé
de nous donner du sang, des tissus, leurs antécédents médicaux
et leurs dossiers médicaux.
Nous avons récolter tout cela.
Nous avons vite appris que cette ressource partagée n'allait pas suffire.
Nous avons décidé qu'il nous fallait faire de la science de la laboratoire poussée --
de la recherche poussée.
Nous avons emprunté des paillasses au labo de Harvard.
Un voisin formidable venait deux fois par semaine
et restait avec les enfants de 20 heures à deux heures du matin
pendant que Pat et moi extrayions de l'ADN,
faisions migrer et évaluions des gels
et cherchions le gène.
Des postdoctoraux généreux nous ont servi de tuteurs.
En quelques années, nous avons trouvé le gène.
Nous l'avons breveté pour qu'il soit accessible gratuitement.
Nous avons créé un test diagnostique.
Nous avons réuni un consortium de recherche.
Nous avons organisé des réunions de recherche
et ouvert un centre d'excellence.
Nous avons trouvé plus de 4 000 personnes à travers le monde atteinte de PXE
et avons tenu des réunions pour patients,
nous avons réalisé des essais et des études cliniques.
A travers tout cela,
nous vivions dans la peur.
La peur de la maladie qui nous suivait de près
alors que l'horloge tournait.
La peur des chercheurs,
si accrédités et si bien positionnés dans un monde fait pour eux.
La peur de prendre les mauvaises décisions.
La peur que les opposants aient raison
et que les chats se contentent de trouver autre chose à manger.
Au-delà de ces peurs, il y avait notre motivation à faire la différence
pour nos enfants et tous ceux rencontrés en chemin.
Très rapidement,
nous avons réalisé que ce que nous faisions pour une maladie,
nous devrions le faire pour toutes.
Nous avons rejoint et fini par diriger
Genetic Alliance :
un réseau de défense de la santé,
de défense des patients,
d'organisations de recherche et de santé.
Nous avons établi des ressources extensibles
comme des biobanques, des archives et des annuaires de soutien
pour toutes les maladies.
Alors que j'apprenais tout sur ces maladies
et ces communautés autour des maladies,
j'ai réalisé qu'il y avait deux secrets dans la santé
qui m'affectaient grandement.
Le premier :
il n'y a pas de réponse toute prête pour les gens comme mes enfants
ou tous les gens avec qui je travaillais,
que leur maladie soit fréquente ou rare.
Le second secret :
la réponse résidait en nous tous
avec le don de nos données,
d'échantillons biologiques
et, finalement, de nous.
Il y a un petit mouvement d'individus
qui travaillent à changer cela.
Les scientifiques citoyens, les activistes, les pirates
qui utilisent une science de crowdsourcing, agissent eux-mêmes,
sont en train de changer la donne.
Même le président Obama et le vice-président Biden
sont des évangélistes de l'idée
selon laquelle les gens devraient être des partenaires en recherche.
C'est un principe fondateur pour notre organisation.
Il est très difficile
de découvrir et de développer des interventions et des traitements.
La science est complexe,
le régime réglementaire est complexe.
Il y a beaucoup d'acteurs avec beaucoup d'intérêts
et des motivations mal alignées
comme une publication, une promotion, un mandat.
Mais je ne blâme pas les scientifiques qui suivent ce chemin
mais je nous mets au défi, eux et nous, de le faire différemment.
De reconnaître que les gens sont au cœur de cela.
Genetic Alliance a fait des essais
pour voir ce qu'il faudrait pour transformer ces systèmes austères.
Notre objectif est de travailler dans limites.
Cela semble abstrait, mais c'est plutôt pratique.
Quand nous sommes frustrés
que les entités ne partagent pas les données --
des données venant des gens ayant donné leur temps, leur énergie, leur sang
et même leurs larmes --
nous devons demander :
« Comment se fait-il que nous pourrions partager mais ne le faisons pas ? »
Nous faisons aussi partie de ce système.
Comment faire en sorte que les gens puissent partager leurs idées librement ?
Afin que les gens prennent des risques et se rapprochent les uns des autres.
Cela mène à une dissolution du « nous » et du « eux »,
pas seulement pour les organisations mais aussi pour les individus.
Si je demande aux organisations ou aux individus
d’œuvrer dans cette direction,
alors je dois explorer qui je suis et quelles sont mes pratiques.
Si je demande aux cliniciens, aux chercheurs et aux administrateurs
de prendre des risques,
alors moi, Sharon, doit également prendre des risques.
Je dois faire face à mes peurs personnelles.
Ma peur de ne pas avoir assez d'influence.
Ma peur de ne pas bien diriger.
Ma peur de ne pas suffire.
Juste avant d'entrer dans l'adolescence, nos enfants ont arrêté net
et ont dit : « Vous devez arrêter de vous inquiéter de faire une différence,
d'avoir de l'influence
et, au lieu de cela, comme nous, apprendre à vivre avec la maladie
plutôt que de la combattre. »
Je dois me demander
d'où cette peur me vient.
La déclaration des enfants a fait la lumière sur cette peur.
Elle trouve ses fondations dans l'amour.
J'aime Elizabeth et Ian.
J'aime les gens atteints de PXE.
J'aime les gens atteints d'une maladie quelconque.
J'aime les gens.
Certains de mes collègues ont découvert que nous ne craignons pas la mort
mais l'énormité de notre amour.
Cet amour expansif m'expose à une grande douleur
face à la perte.
En découvrant ma peur,
j'ai découvert que nous,
moi et tous ceux qui m'entourent,
avons une capacité à aimer qui est infinie.
J'ai aussi découvert
en avançant dans cette peur,
que je pouvais en apprendre beaucoup
et trouver des chemins
vers des choses telles que des solutions pratiques
ainsi que le cœur de la guérison et de la santé.
Je n'ai plus peur comme auparavant.
Récemment, avec un énorme soutien de mes acolytes voyageurs,
j'ai remarqué que ce n'était pas un avertissement comme auparavant.
J'ai remarqué que c'était plutôt
une invitation à aller de l'avant
car on y trouve de l'amour et le chemin vers un amour plus grand.
Si je me tourne vers cette peur avec une douce curiosité,
je trouve une richesse énorme en moi et chez les autres
et une capacité à faire face à des défis que je n'aurais jamais crue possible.
Mes enfants ont encore de l'avance sur moi sur ce chemin.
Aux âges de 29 et 27 ans,
ils se disent heureux et en bonne santé
malgré des manifestations du PXE sur leur peau, leur yeux et leurs artères.
Je vous invite, vous, nous,
à nous tourner vers notre peur ;
à embrasser les choses qui nous effraient
et à trouver l'amour en leur cœur.
Nous ne ferons pas que nous y trouver,
nous pourrons nous imaginer à la place de ceux que nous craignons
et de ceux qui nous craignent.
Si nous respirons cette peur
et sommes vulnérables aux systèmes et aux gens qui nous défient,
notre pouvoir de catalyseurs du changement croît de façon exponentielle.
Quand nous réalisons
que travailler notre vie intérieure, c'est travailler notre vie extérieure
et que le travail externe est du travail interne,
nous en arrivons à ce qui est réel
et des choses sont accomplies.
(Rires)
Il n'y a pas de limite à ce que nous pouvons accomplir ensemble.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)